my name is Donna Qalamoun I have a PhD
in physics physics tends to be quite a
difficult subject so it's always
interesting to see how in the movies
they interpret physics because it's
sometimes good and sometimes a bit wonky
[Music]
using neutrinos acting normally ministry
Mass no electrical charge they pass
through ordinary matter almost
undisturbed okay so what they said there
was that neutrinos normally they come
from the Sun they normally don't
interact with matter so they go through
the earth without actually interacting
with anything which is totally true ten
billion go through every square
centimeter of your body every second it
looks like the neutrinos coming from the
Sun have you take it into a new kind of
nuclear particle
now the neutrinos have mutated into a
new kind of subatomic particle which
interacts with the core of the earth
heating it up
that would be groundbreaking discovery
in terms of like the fundamental
theories of physics which would be
awesome it would suck that the earth was
boiling from the inside as you could see
from that big tank of water
bad design of spacesuit if it's that
easy to take out the critical air
supplied to your head
so I don't think your head would
actually explode if you're on Mars and
you got depressurized
I think you'd suffocate because all of
the air would get sucked out of your
lungs your blood would boil so you'd get
the crazy the bends and yeah things
would really not be good you would not
last long
so he like dried out you're like
desiccated I'm not sure actually you
would lose all the moisture from your
body that quickly is that more realistic
than your head exploding yes yeah this
is a classic someone falling down and
then someone comes along and saves them
by smashing into them like like a
freight train so actually the first to
the Superman film they did it pretty
well it seemed like the catch was pretty
gentle but with the Batman one those two
humans are gonna get snapped by that
cable because it was like a metal cable
with no flex in it whatsoever so as soon
as that catches on the building they're
just gonna go and they're gonna break
all sorts of things I mean probably
Batman's arms gonna get ripped off oh
that Batman movie is so good thing that
might be the best one
[Music]
I guess the question is is that how
mathematicians actually solve
mathematics it tends to be a lot more
argumentative than that I would say
normally it would be someone draws out
the problem and they try and explain it
to us
different people will interpret it with
different levels of confusion and then
at some stage someone gets it and it's
like oh yeah I know what you're doing
now I can try and solve it and then
actually solving things right then and
there in front of a blackboard I think
rarely happens mostly you have to go
away and think about things really
really hard rather than you having these
coy little glances to each other and
being like oh I know the answer whatever
the signal is when they're doing
measurements in of like astronomical
objects you can't always rely on just a
single measurement from a single
telescope telescope because there can be
like systematic errors so people like to
have many different sources like many
different measurements of the same
source and so that has come up recently
in gravitational waves they have three
different gravitational wave detectors
two in America and one in Italy and so
they can kind of triangulate a certain
region and then they can look at it
using the electromagnetic spectrum and I
imagine a lot of the science in contact
has been very well researched because it
was written by Carl Sagan who is
obviously a giant in in communicating
science he wanted a realistic mechanism
to transport the protagonist to Vega
which is on the other side of the galaxy
and so they thought about it and they
came up the idea of wormholes stable
wormholes which are actually allowable
in Einstein's general theory of
relativity so you can have basically a
tunnel of space-time that goes from one
point to the other so Carl Sagan
basically nerd' sniped a load of
theoretical physicists with this
question because then for decades
they've been working out like how these
wormholes these stable traversable
wormholes could exist people have been
trying to
work out all this stuff because it's
just an interesting science question
imagine for a minute that this
attractive piece of paper represents
space-time and you want to get from
point A here it might be there like the
visual example of the bit of paper with
the thing going through it I think
that's totally cool it folds space and
the spacecraft passes through the
Gateway space returns to normal
it does force to Haran in terms of
actual science what he said was he used
magnets use a rotating magnetic field to
make gravitons to focus a narrow beam of
gravitons these and turn fold space-time
consistent with Wales tensor dynamics
and then the gravitons would warp
space-time so those two different forces
and so there's no known way that you
could create gravity using magnets now
[Music]
if you created let's just say you create
the gravitons and creating graviton
somehow warps space-time technically
you're just becoming like a really giant
mass a black hole or something so if you
warped space-time where you are all of
the things around you would start
wanting to fall into you and so that
might be problematic for your spaceship
we used to viewing space as flat right
like this piece of paper this is a long
way across the flat space in between but
given what I was trying to explain we
could form the space so this concept I
didn't realize this concept has turned
into a bit of a cinematic cliché a good
reason that like the original film had
created like a really nice visual image
for something which you know there's
something to that so one thing I really
liked about that is when the lady said
we've spent a huge amount of energy on
this we used huge amount
of energy to create this alright why
can't I see this bridge so yeah the
amount of energy you would need to
expend to make one would be equivalent
to creating a black hole which is like
the remnants of an explosion of the
largest most energetic bodies in our
universe so yeah you're gonna use a
little bit of energy so they say when I
go from here there it's turn into real
cliche so wormhole then space like this
so when you when they were going towards
the black hole the fact that you could
see things reflecting off the surface
almost like galaxies and stars were like
reflecting off it kind of like it's a
mirror I mean that's not technically
correct they are black because anything
that falls into them disappears but you
know that's fine then what they need to
show something otherwise you don't know
what you're looking at there's an
audience so like that's totally fine I
can love that visualization of how from
your perspective what it would like for
all of the everything you see around you
like warp around yourself I was really
cool I really enjoyed it I have other
problems with interstellar apart from
that but that bit of it I think was
really really good
[Applause]
they're checking the electron microscope
and the winner is number three in our
quantum finish no fair you'll change the
outcome by measuring it in quantum
physics when you measure something
that's in a superposition which is the
special state where it's in like this
special mixed state kind of like two
states at once before they measure it
both horses are in a superposition of
winning and not winning at the same time
and then they measure it and then one of
it comes out but according to theory of
quantum physics if you measured that
again you might get the other one see if
each time you measure it you get one
winning or the other one winning 50% of
the time so yeah they've got it bang-on
I was also a really funny joke
[Music]
like their hats their special space hats
well they keep your brain in when when
you explode on the Apollo missions for
sure they had little food packets with
straws in it generally you want to avoid
loose food floating about
I remember one astronaut go into a lot
of trouble for bringing a ham sandwich
on to his pace flight and they were and
they're really worried about the crumbs
getting out and frying the electronics
[Music]
the thing I 2001 is good but it just
takes so long for anything to happen I
don't fall asleep in movies I've fallen
asleep in this movie twice on two
separate occasions yeah it was it was
good boring movie though sorry I know
people love 2001 so gravity got a lot of
things right but this one thing is kind
of the glaring problem in the whole film
what would happen if they were connected
by this tether and he gets pushed
outwards that totally could happen but
as soon as it gets taut hughbanks
backwards again and he would just gently
drift back to her and then they'd go
back to the space station so he would
have been absolutely fine I'm okay with
bad physics and movies because the job
of a movie isn't to be a science
documentary the job of a movie is to
tell an interesting story I just feel
like they could have come up with some
much better physics thing but still I
just it's still frustrating when a film
does so much stuff really correct and
then you've got this one thing that is
like
we have a signal on the luminosity
monitors we have events
[Music]
firework noises
[Music]
man they looked so cool
I really wish like all of physics could
be explained using that kind of
visualization like cinematography they
were talking about suspending antimatter
the antimatter is suspended there using
nano particles and electromagnetism in
an airtight nano composite shell with
electromagnets on each other that's all
good I mean the nano particles they just
put that in because nano particles sound
cool but the containment of antimatter
you do have to do an electromagnetic
field I think the things they actually
use a lot bigger than that because the
magnets that they use have to be giant
antimatter if it combined with matter
does like explode in tons of energy but
if it were to fall out of suspension and
come in contact with matter then the two
opposing forces would annihilate one
another violently but typically the
amounts of antimatter that they store
place it like Cerner so small I don't
think you would get a massive explosion
from it the best bit is them running on
a battery which is gonna run out just
before midnight
don't put your ante rutted storage
devices on battery power prepare the red
matter
I said let go from Westworld oh no you
get this thing with sci-fi films where
they always have to raise the stakes so
there's kind of like an arms race of
like the cool crazy super-powerful stuff
they've got this magical red matter and
that a tiny little piece of this red
matter if you put it in the middle of a
planet it will create a black hole that
will suck the entire planet into it just
a tiny drop look for why the hell is
this ship got so much of this red matter
on it like if if you tripped and bumped
into that vessel containing that red
matter you'd create a black hole big
enough to absorb the entire universe or
something so yeah I give it a fail this
film if you had a telescope you would be
for a star just beaming out such
incredibly high amounts of x-ray
radiation that you're doing everyone
cancer and also for it for you to see
stuff you have to have the detector of
the x-rays at the back so you fire
x-rays through something and then you
get stuff at the back and where the
x-rays are absorbed like by your bones
that's where you get the white bits and
when the x-rays come through you get the
black bits yeah so that's not really
physics
railguns do exist they accelerate
bullets using electromagnetism and in
fact you've got massive giant ones that
can people have thought about launching
things into space using rail guns so
that's a legit thing that's why you
don't use x-ray vision when you're
shooting people because you don't know
who is Arnie and who's a goon like this
see see I'm right again nobody could
have predicted that dr. grant would
suddenly suddenly jump out of a moving
vehicle
so this is not a good description of
chaos theory at all he does explain it
with the butterfly effect the shorthand
is the butterfly effect a butterfly can
flap its wings in Peking and Central
Parking a train is still essential so
that is the essence of chaos theory the
whole thing about the water on the hand
aha okay okay now freezing everything in
don't move I'm gonna do the same thing
start with the same stay in place again
I don't think that's the best
description of it because presumably if
you have water on your hand it will drip
off the same way the last drop of water
did because it's already kind of wetted
that bit of skin so it's more likely
actually that the water will go the same
route that the second bit of water is
why but the point of it actually is is
that Jeff Goldblum's character is just
hitting on Laura Dern's character in
kind of a creepy way so actual fact I
think it's pretty realistic because his
character probably cares more about
hitting on a chick that he does about
getting the right explanation of of
mathematics we haven't actually seen him
again what is this thing it's an
asteroid sir how big are we talking it's
the size of Texas mr. president I mean
it sounds super scary some giant space
rock could just turn up out of nowhere
and slam into the planet I think the one
that caused the extinction of the
dinosaurs was 5 kilometers wide so I
don't know how big Texas is but it's way
way bigger than that we need you to prep
the team we're sending up we'll send
them to the asteroid they'll land
they'll drill a hole they'll drop some
nukes take off and detonate if we can
fix this equipment problem that's a
really bad idea if you do that you
basically turn it from from like a
single bullet into a shotgun blast so
then you've just got loads of slightly
smaller asteroids that are all
radioactive
yes there's very real possibility the
probability of it is incredibly low and
is interesting hearing the different
ideas people have some as simple as you
go up there with a spaceship and you
just paint one side white and the other
side black and it if you do it early
enough it'll pick up enough solar
radiation from the Sun on the white side
that it will actually deflect it a
certain amount and then what was another
another one was attach rockets to the
side of it and then deflect it sideways
to again a deflect the orbit exploding
with the giant nuclear bomb is is not
the best idea
I think painting it but painting is not
gonna make an exciting move we have to
paint it white I don't know but they
constructed this three-dimensional space
inside their five-dimensional reality to
allow you to understand it time is
represented here as a physical dimension
like the visualizations in
film is so cool when you look in
different directions things line up and
so it looks like you can travel through
different things and that would be kind
of so hard to do to kind of imagine
higher dimensions and how geometry works
they had made time into a physical
dimension so as he traveled in certain
directions he could find that the time
he was looking for but the thing that
was navigating him through that higher
dimensional space was the power of love
it's like I found this moment how the
love tars love and that's the bitter
feeling where I was just like maybe I'm
just not sentimental enough but I mean
come on he's seriously not to belittle
love I love love it's good but I feel
like it actually ruins it to reduce love
to some kind of physical physics physics
is so basic I have no problem with wonky
science in movies I even kind of enjoy
it to be honest because it's fun to try
and imagine the kind of things that
they're saying it can be kind of quite
imaginative actually what how you
interpret it when they say things wrong
the problem I have isn't with bad
science and films the problem I have is
bad films in films
[Music]
this is here Miller is this a military
kind of installation because I find that
there's often science and the military
come together in these sci-fi movies and
the scientists are always like trying to
explain things and the military people
are always just like no I need a yes or
no answer now I mean geez they control
the nuclear bombs I hope they're not
just like don't give me a jibber Jarrah
is it nuclear or not Denzel Washington
getting really angry about science
[Music]